okay
so let's try let's like really try this
experiment if you ran
way more let's say they're i don't know
if you agree but
they seem to be at the head of the pack
of the kind of
uh what would you call that approach
like it's not necessarily lighter based
because it's not about lighter but
before roman tax
level four robot taxi all in before any
before making any revenue
uh so they're probably at the head of
the pack if you were
said uh hey george can you please run
this company for a year how would you
change it uh i would go i would get
anthony levandowski out of jail and i
would put him in charge of the company
um let's try to break that apart
why do you do you want to make do you
want to destroy the company by doing
that or
do you mean or do you mean uh you like
renegade style thinking that uh pushes
that that like throws away bureaucracy
and goes to first principle thinking
what
what do you mean by that um i think
anthony lewandowski is a genius
and i think he would come up with a much
better idea of what to do with waymo
than me
so you mean that unironically he is a
genius oh yes oh absolutely
without a doubt i mean i'm not saying
there's no shortcomings
but in the interactions i've had with
him yeah
um he's also willing to take like who
knows what he would do with waymo
i mean he's also out there like far more
out there than i am yeah there's big
risks
yeah what do you make of him i was i was
going to talk to him in this podcast and
i was going back and forth
i'm i'm such a gullible naive human like
i see the best in people
and i slowly started to realize that
there might be some people out there
that like have multiple
faces to the world they're like
deceiving and dishonest i still
refuse to like i i just i trust people
and i don't care if i get hurt by it but
like
you know sometimes you have to be a
little bit careful especially platform
wise and
podcast wise what do you what am i
supposed to think
so you think you think he's a good
person
oh i don't know i don't really make
moral judgments
it's difficult to oh i know i mean this
about the waymo actually i mean that
whole idea very non-ironically about
what i would do
the problem with putting me in charge of
waymo is waymo is already
10 billion dollars in the hull right
whatever idea waymo does look
com is profitable has raised 8.1 million
that's small
you know that's small money like i can
build a reasonable consumer electronics
company
and succeed wildly at that and still
never be able to pay back waymo's 10
billion
so i i think the basic idea with waymo
we'll forget the 10 billion because they
have some backing but
your basic thing is like what can we do
to stop making some money
well no i mean my bigger idea is like
whatever the idea is that's going to
save waymo
i don't have it it's going to have to be
a big risk idea and i cannot think of a
better person than anthony lewandowski
to do it
so that is completely what i would do as
ceo of waymo i call myself a
transitionary ceo
do everything i can to fix that
situation yeah
uh yeah cause i can't i can't do it
right like i can't i can't
oh i mean i can talk about how what i
really want to do is just apologize for
all those corny
uh you know ad campaigns and be like
here's the real estate of the technology
yeah um like i have several criticism
i'm a little bit more bullish on
waymo than than you seem to be but
one criticism i have is it went into
corny mode too early
like it's still a startup it hasn't
delivered on anything so it should be
like more renegade
and show off the engineering that
they're doing which just can be
impressive as opposed to doing these
weird commercials of like
your friendly yeah your your friendly
car company
i mean that's my biggest my biggest
snipe at waymo was always
that guy's a paid actor that guy's not a
waymo user he's a paid actor look here i
found his call sheet
do kind of like what spacex is doing
with uh the rocket launches just
get put the nerds up front put the
engineers up front and just like show
failures too
just i love i love spacex's yeah yeah
the thing they're doing it is right and
it just feels like the right
but we're all so excited to see them
succeed yeah i can't wait to see when it
won't fail
you know like you lie to me i want you
to fail you tell me the truth you'll be
honest with me i want you to succeed
yeah
uh yeah and that requires the uh the
renegade ceo
right i'm with you i'm with you i still
have a little bit of faith in waymo to
for for the renegade ceo to step
forward but it's not it's not
john crafter yeah it's uh
you can't it's not chris homestead and
those people may be very good at certain
things yeah
but they're not renegades because these
companies are fundamentally even though
we're talking about billion dollars
all these crazy numbers they're still
like early stage startups
i mean i i just i if you are pre-revenue
and you've raised 10 billion dollars i
have no idea like
like this just doesn't work no it's
against everything silicon valley
where's your minimum viable product
you know where's your users what's your
growth numbers
this is traditional silicon valley why
do you not apply it to what you think
you're too big to fail already
like
you